why do you think
uh ayn rand is such a controversial
figure last time i spoke with you on
this particular podcast
the um the amount of emails i've gotten
are positive and negative
and certainly negative i don't usually
get negative emails
yeah i can't i can't relate i'm sure
mine were all positive
overwhelmingly positive it was mostly uh
women sending the pictures
uh for me to forward to you because you
didn't send me that
i ca
[Laughter]
why do you think she's such a divisive
figure uh why do you think
that she provokes such emotion in both
the positive and the negative side i'd
love to hear both of your
viewpoints on this well i think on the
negative side and both on the positive
and the negative side i think it's
because she's
radical she's consistently radical
she up ends the the uh
premises the ideas that are prevalent in
the culture that were brought up on that
that are like you know uh
like milken and uh and and you know the
basic
stuff that we're growing up you have to
be altruistic you have to live for other
people
that's just basic stuff nobody
challenges that nobody questions it
and if they do question it they usually
question it from the perspective of
a cynic or a a bad guy right you made to
the
the joker right before we started right
that you know i'm gonna upend the world
because i don't care about other people
right so so they're presented with these
two alternatives and it's real in
people's lives right
you either live for other people or
you're a
evil sob um and you know yeah most
people are neither one of those
but the ethic is right here it's it's
living for the people
and when you challenge that they have no
way cognitive to go with that
and the only place they can go with that
cognitively is to the joker
it's the evil guy it's the somebody who
wants to smash everything and destroy
because they don't have this alternative
conception of oh no you can be
rationally self-interested and that does
not involve destruction and that does
not involve
you know they're exploiting other people
they can't conceptualize that it's not
in their framework
um so it's the fact that she's so
consistently
on the side of self-interest for example
on the side of capitalism
on the side of freedom uh it's the fact
that she
dismisses faith to the extent that she
does or the extent that i do
right that alienates people because that
is completely different from what they
brought up now the flip side of that is
it's also really interesting to some
people so
you know a lot of you got some positives
right um
and i got a lot of positives from that
appearance i know a lot of people came
to my podcast because i appeared on your
show
why because they hear something that's
completely fresh
new different they've never heard before
it appeals to something in them that
maybe you know a lot of people say i
read ein rand and it confirmed
everything i believed
now for me it didn't it was the opposite
it turned upside down everything i
believe
but there are a lot of people out there
that who have a sense that something's
wrong in the world
that altruism is wrong that socialism
just the stuff
and and religion is wrong but they don't
have an alternative it hasn't coalesced
and they listen to a lot of podcasts
because they're trying to get ideas of
what is it what is it that i'm sensing
that's wrong out there
and suddenly somebody comes out and
gives them some clear explanation of
things and they go
wow that's what i've been looking for my
whole life so that's the positive
for for people um you know and i read
ein rand
it just all made sense it all clicked
and all in and it made clear that
everything i believed to that point was
just wrong
it just didn't it didn't integrate and i
always knew to some extent it didn't
integrate
but there was no alternative so i
believed it what else was there i i
remember saying to myself as a kid
probably 15. why should i why is this
why is morality all about other people
why is that well that's just the way it
is right
and and i couldn't couldn't come up with
an explanation she gave me the
explanation
and she gave me the explanation why it's
wrong to do that and i think
so i think that's why people respond
it's just too radical it can't
fit into their cognitive framework that
they're being brought up on that they've
been educated on that that just
their whole life revolves around michael
you don't bring up iran
that much in conversation except us kind
of references every once in a while as
part of the humor
of just the general flow and the music
or the way you like to talk
well why do you think you don't
integrate
her into your philosophy when you're
like explaining ideas and all those
kinds of things
like why is she not you know a popular
reference point for discussion of ideas
because
i i don't know if euron's going to agree
with or can't agree with me
i think for a certain percentage of
population actually i talked to someone
from the iran institute i forgot his
name older guy with glasses and
he didn't disagree with me he said this
is changing i said i think for a certain
percentage population
who are uninformed about her work higher
than 10 percent less than 50 percent
you mentioned on rand they have been
trained to think this is identical
scientology
so as soon as her name comes up it's
like okay i'm out the door i don't i'm
not gonna have anything to do with this
and everyone who follows her is a crazy
person that's one thing that has
happened
another thing is rand in her um
personality
was very aggressive and antagonistic she
was for a long time
the lone voice in the wilderness being
like this isn't like
uh like one of her big adversaries in a
certain sense as milton friedman
and she really hated how milton friedman
was like oh you know
having rent control is inefficient and
she's like inefficient
we're talking about mass homelessness
and people
dying and you're talking about this like
what color
pie goes with this color shirt are you
in like
and in fact it's hilarious uh there was
an organization called the foundation
economic education fee
leonard reed was the head of this and
there were a series of letters and she
was helping him she was much more
philosophically grounded in certain
contexts than he was and there was an
essay a pamphlet
that he published called roofs or
ceilings it was co-written by
milton friedman later nobel prize winner
and george stigler also later nobel
prize winner
and basically the argument was well
if the government controls all housing
how's that going to work out
and she's sitting there and she's typing
in all caps
so you know she's holding on the [ __ ]
and doing this
on a typewriter and being like how
and you can imagine her at with her
cigarette holder apoplectic
being like how is an organization
ostensibly
devoted to free enterprise discussing
these this stalinist idea in the most
casual of terms
she's like have i taught you not and
what's amazing is so
at fee they only have her letters
because
she sent them to read the iran institute
must have leonard reid
or letter i was able to knowing rand
enough predict
exactly what the conversation would go
like because he also did something she
didn't approve of which is
he asked other people for uh feedback on
her work and she goes
i gave this to you to read who are you
shopping around to some jerk that i
don't
i need their approval what are you doing
so it was a very uh interesting
situation
but so that's one issue i don't remember
this is ain't rand when she's young
nice right yeah it's before after short
it was before
so it's before she's super famous and
before this is just the fun has been
published
but but you know she's she's
trying to work with others and they're
disappointing her left and right
yeah so and also when you are
a what she takes away from bad
people is you have these kids right
and you're gonna sit down with them and
they're gonna be like yeah i'm gonna
take your
guns i'm gonna lock you in your house um
i'm gonna take 60
of your income and all this other stuff
and they
might up to reading rand they might sit
down and have a discussion
and rand goes hey you know what you
didn't have to give them an answer
you could say go to hell we're not
having this conversation
and you have no right to one second of
my life
and this is not a legitimate opener this
is a declaration of war this isn't like
it's not like if i sit down with you
iran i'm like hey ron here are my plans
for your wife
go to hell yeah this isn't a
conversation we're having oh i'm gonna
make you unsafe in your house what this
is not a discussion
so what happens is these people who five
minutes ago were able to have a debate
with this
kid because people read ran when they're
young often and now that kid is like
yeah i'm not even talking to you
it's her fault whereas in reality it's
that person's fault
because that person had no right
although they've been trained to the
contrary by our culture
to believe yeah i'm going to sit down
and we're just going to equally
have a discussion over your own's life
and you have one vote and i have one
vote and we're going to
alex has a vote and that's how it's
going to be and rand's not having it
yeah
um so i think those are two issues and
there's some other things which which i
don't need to get into but
i i because one of the things that ran
said consisting her life
is that her philosophy is an integrated
whole right
so to be an objective isn't just like i
like atlas shrugged it means
i accept objectivism as a totality since
i do not
i don't i think it is proper to be
respectful to her wishes
and not constantly be especially given
that i have somewhat of a platform to be
like iron and iron and rand
because i don't think ein rand would
have liked it if i was talking about
iran this much
so how do you how do you deprogram
because i
i don't like to bring up iran just
because i do see what uh
like how people roll their eyes
essentially so how
what's the outside exactly but what is
that pro can we can you speak to that
programming
i think that people have people i mean
look at the end of the day
if you talk about the ideas and the
ideas make sense and people are
attracted to the ideas and you say oh by
the way and this came from mine rand
that's how you de-program them right if
you make the ideas prevalent in the
culture if people start viewing
self-interest as something that's kind
of that's interesting and worthwhile
and something worth investigating and
they said oh that came from my man then
i think i think that we'll we'll
de-program them and get them
and get them changing their minds about
these things and also you know going on
shows where
uh people are gonna watch your show no
matter who you bring on right so uh
even though now you do you if you put on
you you
you put iran in the title that
immediately reduces the number of people
who watch
so so in the future you should you put
back in the title and then at least the
the female speculation too the female to
you
so so you go and you try to make them as
credible as possible to as many people
as possible over time
it takes time and ultimately i don't
think the culture will have this
response to her
they might still disagree with her but i
think over time and already you're
seeing it younger people i think today
are far less there was a generation who
never read ein rant
and was like this bring out the garlic
in the crosses we don't want to have
anything to do with her
then and and i think today there are
many more people who've read her and
might disagree or not disagree right and
then
there are a lot of people who haven't
read her but who are not opposed to it
or willing to have any
to engage so i think it's changing
already and i think in 20 years it'll be
completely different and
there's two more things that she does
that i think it says that i think people
find very very off-putting given
our culture one is she will basically
you could sit down with rand and be like
your fear is not in any way a hold on my
freedom
just that one sentence and for a lot of
people that's very off-putting
uh and very harsh it's correct
but for them it's just like wait a
minute i i'm still scared it's like i
don't care
like for example like with lockdowns and
things like this it's like well
i'm scared and maybe i have a right to
be scared ah like i'm scared that you
have a gun in your house
and it's like i respect that you're
scared i don't care at the end
at the as you say at the end of the day
this is my house i'm going to live my
life
as i please as long as i don't hurt
other people well you are hurting me
because i'm scared
no that's not this is the feeling versus
fact yeah yeah
so that is one situation like the
feeling versus
freedom yes where rand i mean puts a lot
of people off
um i also think that historically
a lot of people who were drawn to her
are drawn to her for the wrong reasons
that a lot of times like howard rourke
uh the the
hero we're gonna still stay here are you
supposed to say protagonist but hero
the hero of the fountainhead he's
extremely intelligent
but he's also extremely uncompromising
what often ends up happening is you'll
have a young kid
who is somewhat intelligent but then
they pick up the personality
and now you're someone i can't work with
and then it's like you're not how i'd
work relax
you're not that skilled you're not that
talented but because the character has
to be personification
and have certain aspects together when
kids read that they're gonna might get
the wrong idea and that's not rand's
fault and it's more than that it's it's
so so i i completely agree with that but
it's it's even broader than that so
so here is a in my view you know one of
the geniuses of the millennium
presenting a philosophy
and she's got not just the questions in
my view she's got the answers and you're
reading them at 16
and you're reading the answers you don't
know at 16 that this is true yeah yeah
you might have a sense that it's true
but you don't have the life experience
the learned experience
you don't have the facts you don't have
the knowledge you're picking up truth
it's just being absorbed you're
accepting it as true but you don't know
it's true
and then you go out into the world
advocating for it right which we all did
or at least i did when i was 16. and
you're obnoxious
you can't prove what you're arguing yeah
because you don't have the experience it
took me
i don't know 10 20 years probably 20 to
figure out
that i really do think she what she said
was true right
but i didn't know when i was 16 when i
was 16 i just absorbed these ideas
and accepted them in a sense you know
with some connection to reality but a
sense
on faith right at least presented it
that way
um and you and and as a consequence you
come off as a detached from reality
obnoxious uh human being i think a lot
of young objectivists are and it's hard
not to be
because you are you're confronted with
genius and you're not a genius i
certainly am not a genius
and i'm confronted with just genius and
have all this information in my head now
i can't articulate it i
and it's hard to deal with yourself what
there's an inside joke yeah you said i
could find a genius that point to us
yeah
yeah i mean i'm confronted with you guys
i'm i'm at an age where i know how to
deal with geniuses
um but i'm gonna there's something else
this is not why people don't like her
but there's something that the
fountainhead does which i think is very
uh um and i don't i don't blame her but
it's a bad consequence
if you read the fountainhead and you're
young and you're intelligent and
talented
the message at least i got and i know
i'm not alone is you are going to think
that you're going to be a pariah
that a lot of people are going to be
against you and you're going to you're
basically doing for a short period
of being isolated and alone and that may
have been the case when the fountainhead
was written
but i think now with the internet and in
my experience both as a youth
and someone who's a little bit older i
didn't appreciate and you're not going
to get it from that book and you can't
get it through that book because it has
to have a certain narrative
how many people who are a little older
are giddy
when they find young talent how
inspiring it is how exciting it is like
when you talk to these kids who are
doing things on the internet
or writing or whatever achievement you
want them to flourish
you don't you're not threatened by them
as the antagonists of the fountainhead
are
and that doesn't come through in the
fountainhead because it depends on your
profession right i mean for
certain parts of the world are better
than others if you're of course if
you're an
artist this is the way i can see vervat
uh and you you want to go study art
today
you're going to be and look down and and
so on so so yeah i agree
i mean and and in my generation when i
read i ran you know there was no
internet
there was and i was in israel so we were
isolated and there was nobody else who
had shared their ideas
and he did feel that kind of isolation
and and but rook gave you
to me he didn't teach me about you know
you're going to be isolated because
partially because i wasn't um
maybe i was i was humble right um
when i when i read atlas shrugged i
identified with eddie willis
okay when i read the font hit i didn't
identify with hard work how old did you
read the fountainhead
so i read atlas when i was 16 i probably
would have uh phone hit when i was 16
and a half 17 something like that
that is and i read it and i and i you
really had the fountain head after alice
shrugged yeah
if anyone listening to this they should
read funny if you read it
for me after atlas shrugged no that is a
war crime no for me
reading was much more outnumbered it is
more important
but my point is i think the fountainhead
in many ways is redundant in certain
aspects if you read atlas shrugged first
and because the fountainhead is such a
masterful book and such a personal book
i agree i agree with i agree with that
so ideally you would read the foundation
that's what i'm saying yes
um but and here's the other thing people
don't appreciate i'm starting to wrap
you up uh
people think rand's always about
politics politics political politics
fountainhead is not a political book at
all it's about well she talks about
politics and man's soul sure sure
but it's about ethics how important
everyone has to have a moral code
that's the other thing why people find
randolph-pudding if you have young
people
who now find it very important to live a
moral life
who are like what does that mean to have
morality to have ethics
to live with integrity for people who
have
gotten a little older who have made
these little sacrifices
who are like i'm not going to fight at
work do i really need to look for
another job
yeah my wife's kind of you know getting
annoying but am i going to make a fight
about it
these little sacrifices that they make
every day big ones
and big ones absolutely so when you have
someone who's saying
forcing you to look in the mirror and
say
those little sacrifices that mix
actually made you did the wrong thing
and you're evading that you betrayed
your unconscious
that to many people i think is very
threatening but this is why
so many people say that ein rand is for
14 year old boys yeah
right right and there's a reason why
there's a reason why it appeals to 14 is
a little young but but 16 18
it's because those are the ages where we
we're still open to idealism idealism in
a positive sense
right to to to beautiful things to
ideals to to
to to seeking perfection seeking uh to
seeking a great life
i think as you grow older most people
become cynical they give up on their
ideas why because their ideals were
wrong
and their ideas failed yeah right my
parents were socialist
when they were young those ideas failed
so where do you go from socialism if
you're ideal for cynicism yeah the
citizens
which is right all adults almost all
adults out there are cynical and
and that is that is that is failed
idealism and when they look at the young
people they see their idealism
oh well that's that i was idealistic too
and they don't
question the idea well they're good
ideals and they're bad ideas the right
ideas and the wrong ideas
and uh and and that's why they
attributed to they attributed to youth
so it's a threat
to a lot of people a lot of people who
it's too late for for some people it's
too late to change their minds
and and they know it and and they've too
invested in it
in the job and the wife and the in the
compromises in the comfort
and the comfort and the current they're
too invested in the comfort to cut to
to invest in a compromise to invest in a
comfort and they know
that they shouldn't be they know they
should change and these young people
are challenging that and that is really
really scary for them and that's
that's why they reject her without even
without too much consideration
one of the things ran the working title
for fountain head was secondhand lives
and ran had two definitions of
selfishness in that book one is
selfishness in the sense of
my life is the most important thing it's
not the only important thing
my family would be number two friends
they certainly are extremely high values
but you can't have these secondary
values without the first value but in
the context of my life right because
your family might not be about you
right right you might hate your parents
sure the point being selfishness
then there's the other kind of
selfishness which is peter keating one
of the villains of the book
which is he's selfish in that he's
greedy he's looking out for number one
but he has no values
he has no sense of character he just
wants to be wealthy
he wants to have a beautiful wife he
wants to have a big house
why he couldn't tell you because other
people have it and he wants to have it
more than them
his sense of reference is other people
he's living
second hand what the problem with that
is a lot of young people read rand
and when they start arguing online they
just start trying to talk like rand
whereas rand would be like be original
be an innovator if you want to argue for
objectivism and ran's views
take her ideas articulate them in your
own way because that's a good way of
showing
that you understand what she thinks but
what they end up doing
is just talking like her it sounds dated
and comical
and that's going to be off-putting
because it's like rand wouldn't expect
someone else to sound like rand
she's uh you know her own person and she
of course wouldn't
view keating as selfish in any sense
because or even greedy
greed is a tricky word but so selfish in
the old school sense
yeah he's selfish in the oats but but
even there he it's not as if
it's not as if he has some passion and
he's going after that passion no matter
what i'm gonna
you know light she'd steal i'm gonna he
he doesn't have
his passion is painting right and he
doesn't pursue his passion
he pursues what his mother wants us to
pursue and he pursues money and
he's completely second-handed in the
sense that he follows other people's
values not his own
you